the final piece of arguing is that you
actually have to you actually have to I
would say radiate a certain sense of
calm and niceness what this means is
that if somebody comes at you in a
polite way you're not allowed to hit
them with a club okay so I owe my rule
and debate is that you get to pick the
weapon of your choice right it's like an
oil it's like an old-fashioned medieval
duel you get to pick the rapier or you
get to pick the mace and train and it's
your choice I'm happy to argue anyway
you want to argue and if you want to
have a really nice calm polite
conversation I am more than happy to do
that it's what I prefer if you want to
be a jerk then I'm gonna hit you really
really hard and what this means is that
you can never actually be seen as the
bad guy because when you're seen as a
bad guys when you go totally
disproportionate when you go totally
disproportionate you're seen as the bad
guy unless the audience is already just
angry at the person that you're arguing
with or then you want to see Donald
Trump put you up Bush through a wall or
something but if but but otherwise if
you're just debating with somebody as
tempting as it is you cannot body slam
them if they are just happy trying to
play by Marquis of Queensberry rules by
the same token if they start punching
below the belt finish them or if they
start punching below the belt you put
them down for the count and that means
it means using every tool at your
disposal it's the same thing your dad
taught you guys when you're growing up
about dealing with bullies right that if
they punch you you finish the fight but
you don't start the fight it's the same
thing that's that's true in debate so
what comes to mind is I was once
debating Chang Tiger and we were doing
this this big debate in front of about
3,000 people and chanc had done debates
the previous two years of the Ann
Coulter and dinesh d'souza and in both
of those debates he won really low in
both of those debates he'd come up with
this list of quotes from both of them
and just read quotes at them to be
really nasty and nut and neither Dinesh
nor an were really prepared for that
because by actual personal interaction
they're both very polite people I know
both of them friendly with both of them
and so they weren't expecting that they
were expecting just have a normal debate
and instead Chang came out and with the
kitchen sink I was expecting Chang to
come out with the kitchen sink and so I
had eight pages of stuff in my pocket
literally eight pages of stuff right
here and if he had gone low I would have
hit him so hard I would have finished
his career on the stage if you'd gone
well I mean it was I mean I I was I had
quote after quote from him about his
denial of the Armenian Genocide I mean I
was willing to go there and instead
Chang because he was smart enough to
realize that the audience was kind of
stacked against him I think he had a
polite debate we had a perfectly nice
polite
fate on Medicare Medicaid and healthcare
spending and all this kind of stuff I
really would have preferred for it to go
folks it would been spectacular video
but but since it did not I did not have
the ability it was not my job to go low
so you get you the other person gets to
pick the weapon and then you finish them
with their own weapon that's what makes
you a really good debater